monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre madame la
ministre messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues
eh bien oui la guerre est de retour
en europe et avec elle ses images que
nous pensions appartenir définitivement
au passé les sirènes hurlantes dans les
villes ukrainiennes
la population qui se masse sous terre et
les civils femmes enfants vieillards qui
sont jetés sur les routes de l'exode
l'histoire est de retour aussi
l'histoire se rappelle à nos mémoires
bien sûr il y a
actuellement dans toute la france dans
tous les esprits une émotion légitime
mais parce que nous sommes parlementaire
nous nous tiendrons monsieur le premier
ministre a un devoir patriotique d'unité
je ne détournerait pas mon propos sur
une ligne plus
politique je veux me tenir à l'essentiel
et
répondre peut-être parce que nous sommes
des parlementaires des hommes et des
femmes public à deux questions
essentielles la première c'est que faire
maintenant et la seconde c'est que
faut-il penser quelle est la
signification de cette guerre le prison
de république à juste titre je le dis a
parlé de tournant et c'est un tournant
mais quel sera ce monde d'après comment
s'y préparer
d'abord que faire parler clair bien sûr
parler clair
désigné l'agresseur il y a pu par le
passé y avoir des erreurs occidentale
mais aucune erreur aucune ne serait ni
expliquer ni excuser
l'agression et l'offensive armée de
vladimir poutine contre un état libre
indépendant l'ukraine je le dis
solennellement à cette tribune mes chers
amis
cette agression il a habillé avec une
rhétorique grossière et il la mène pour
de mauvaises raisons
cette rhétorique grossière avec les
termes que vous avez vous même souligné
monsieur le premier ministre
nazification génocide
sont hors de propos la dernière fois que
kiev a été attaquée c'était en 1941 par
les nazis précisément quand au terme de
génocide peut-être faut-il aussi
rappeler
au delà de ce terme est peut-être en
utilisant l'expression d'un crime contre
l'humanité ce que les ukrainiens ont
appelé l'holodomor c'est à dire le
massacre par la famine voulu voulue par
staline en 1932 chers collègues
vladimir poutine l'a fait pour de
mauvaises raisons la première c'est que
il ne supporte pas à la frontière
occidentale de la russie
un pays
démocratique une démocratie c'est une
mauvaise raison bien mauvaises raisons
et l'autre raison c'est que
certains fêteront si j'ose dire
le 100e anniversaire la fin de cette
année de la constitution d'une union
soviétique et c'est à ce moment là qu'il
choisit d'attaquer un pays frère
l'ukraine parce qu'il veut laver
pense-t-il dans sa tête la grande
humiliation de l'effondrement de l'union
soviétique et simplement je veux
rappeler une de ses phrases prémonitoire
qu'il a prononcé en 2005 il a dit ce qui
ne regrette pas l'effondrement du nom
soviétique n'ont pas de coeur mais ceux
qui veulent reconstituer
l'union soviétique n'ont pas de cerveau
c'était une phrase sans doute
prémonitoire bien évidemment et lui
aujourd'hui à lui seul voeu récapituler
toute l'histoire eu celle d'avant la
révolution celle des 10 à celle d'après
la révolution celle des soviets
alors maintenant
que faire et que dire mais que dire
encore et vous avez raison nous devons
monsieur le premier ministre mener une
guerre informationnel nous en parlions
l'autre jour à propos du mali du sahel
et prenons l'exemple magnifique
spectaculaire du président et des skis
se filmant avec son portable ce week-end
vous l'avez vu comme moi devant des
bâtiments publics à kiev cette guerre
nous devons la mener pour dissocier le
régime russe du peuple russe qui est un
grand peuple cette âme slave qui a donné
à l'humanité parmi les plus grandes
oeuvres littéraires avec tolstoï avec
duster et qui avec seul génie jean et
bien d'autres elle a même donné
d'ailleurs un académicien français andré
mike keane voudrais leur dire et puis au
delà du parler vrai il faut agir vite et
fort
agir vite et fort parce que vladimir
poutine a parié sur notre incapacité à
défendre nos valeurs nos intérêts il a
fait ce pari pensant que
finalement notre réaction se limiterait
à des protestations officielles à des
indignations outragé et c'est un bonheur
de voir qu'il s'est trompé qu'il s'est
trompé sur toute la ligne 161 le général
de gaulle au moment même du coup de
force du kremlin contre le berlin a eu
cette phrase il parlait bien sûr
d'impérialisme soviétique à l'époque il
avait dit tout recul pour peut avoir
pour effet de surexcités l'adversaire
vladimir poutine ne comprend que le
rapport de force et je suis attaché
comme chacun d'entre vous à la
négociation parce que demain il faudra
trouver un compromis un chemin pour la
paix évidemment mais nous ne le
trouveront pas as seen in installons pas
au préalable un vrai rapport de force
avec vladimir poutine
alors que faire bien sûr les sanctions
je me félicite je trouvais la semaine
dernière qu'elle est est trop graduelle
par phases trop peu massive vous en
avions parlé à matignon premier ministre
mais depuis ce week-end franchement
jamais dans l'histoire récente je n'ai
vu
des sanctions si massive aussi rapide et
à ceux qui doutent je veux simplement
dire que elles vont bien sûr toucher
l'économie russe mais mais surtout elles
sont aussi un signe elles sont la mesure
de notre détermination j'ai aussi
entendu des critiques en disant eh oui
mais elles sont efficaces parce que nous
allons en pâtir il va y avoir un
retournement bien sûr alors là il faudra
convoquer bien évidemment parce qu'il
sera légitime cette fois ci le quoi
qu'il en coûte de l'état mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que personne ne veut
mourir pour kiev et on va pas mes chers
collègues sur ajouter une guerre
mondiale à une guerre régionale personne
mais si personne ne veut se gêner pour
kiev alors arrêtons les gesticulations
rendons-nous en cortège à munich
abandonnent ou à ce monde qu avait
décrit un jour vaclav havel ce monde
sans histoire histoire avec un grand h
majuscule ce monde sans histoire
uniquement rythmée par les petits soucis
privé ça n'est pas de ce monde dont nous
voulons pour nous et pour nos enfants
bien évidemment et puis que devons-nous
faire ce que vous faites sur
l'initiative du chef de l'état monsieur
le premier ministre
renforcer les positions orientale de
l'otan pologne en estonie mais aussi en
roumanie là aussi un double message un
message
de détermination de fermeté mais surtout
un message d'unité et au passage
observant que le président de la
fédération de russie aura finalement
réussi à réveiller l'otan qui était soi
disant en état de mort cérébrale il aura
même peut-être créer l'ukraine
pense-t-il nous pensons nous que
l'ukraine et résister mais il a suscité
un mouvement un élan national comme
jamais en ukraine et et cela je pense
que il faut le dire aussi et puis bien
sûr
et dont le peuple ukrainien comme nous
le faisons nous devons le faire ce
toutes les formes possibles imaginales
je le dis comme j'ai pu le dire dans
d'autres lieux nous devrons accepter de
recevoir des réfugiés seasons ils sont
très peu nombreux et ces femmes et ces
enfants
ce sera l'honneur
ce sera l'honneur de la france alors
faut-il dans la précipitation
accepté l'adhésion de l'ukraine à
l'union européenne très franchement
je pense qu'il faut être prudent très
franchement je pense que ça pourrait
être contre-productif aussi bien pour
l'ukraine nous ne devons pas jeter de
l'huile sur le feu au moment nous
voulons trouver ce sentier de la paix et
je pense que ça pourrait être aussi
contre-productif bien sûr pour l'europe
elle même qui se diluerait dans des
élargissements successifs
voilà je pense qu'on a beaucoup de
moyens d'aider l'ukraine et je pense que
toutes ces actions très déterminée ne
doivent jamais oublier
la désescalade une possibilité de
désescalade ne doivent jamais oublier
aussi que la voie diplomatique tous les
canaux doivent être constamment ouvert
et nous les responsables publics
ministre comme sénateur ou député nous
devons faire attention à la grammaire à
notre vocabulaire ne pas nous laisser
griser par des mots qui sont autant
d'agressions inutile
enfin
seconde question que penser quelle est
la signification de cette guerre pour la
communauté internationale d'abord elle
souligne bien sûr la grande fragilité de
nos institutions du multilatéralisme en
réalité l'ordre l'ordre de la paix
internationale d'après la guerre est
chancelant et avec lui ses belles et
grandes illusions sur la fin de
l'histoire sur l'unification de la
planète sous les doubles auspices du
droit et du mach les du marché je pense
que il faudra être très imaginatif et en
réalité avec cette guerre et 21 ans
après les attentats du 11 septembre nous
entrons définitivement dans le 21e
siècle mais nous y entrons
malheureusement avec les institutions
que nous a laissé le xxème siècle où il
faudra beaucoup d'audace pour refonder
et faire renaître les institutions du
d'un nouveau multilatéralisme
oui il faudra refonder ce lien entre les
états unis l'europe ce sera plus facile
pour la france que pour certains nos
partenaires il faudra sans doute
s'inspirer d'une formule qui avait été
celle d'hubert védrine amis
bien sûr allié mais non-alignés et il
faudra construire un vrai pilier
européen pour l'otan je pense que quand
j'écoute ce qu'a dit le chancelier
allemand nous sommes à un moment est à
la croisée de chemins il y a une
opportunité justement historique pour
que au moins en europe on puisse saisir
cette chance je crois aussi que la
france madame la ministre aura une
position singulière nous sommes le seul
pays des vingt-sept avoir un siège
permanent au conseil de sécurité
seule puissance nucléaire seul pays avec
une vraie armée avec un modèle complet
avec une diplomatie déquilibre sachant
parler avec l'est avec l'ouest avec le
nord et puis le sud et enfin pour
l'europe bien sûr pour l'europe c'est le
réveil il est brutal mais il ya réveil
l'europe est née pour un autre monde un
nom un monde qui a cru comme benjamin
constant que
la fin lâche de la guerre était terminée
et que l'âge du commerce commencé et
nous nous réveillons brutalement de ce
monde où où le tragique est de retour la
guerre est de retour le rapport le
rapport de force archaïque nous avons
affaibli notre souveraineté nous avons
affaibli nos capacités de puissance il
faudra restaurer la souveraineté
souveraineté alimentaire au moment où un
programme européen voudrait diminuer de
production farm to fork il faudra
restaurer notre souveraineté énergétique
au moment où tentes avaient voulu nous
faire quitter justement l'énergie
nucléaire qui assure notre souveraineté
il faudra aussi rappelé aux juges
européens
avec la directive sur le temps de
travail appliqué à nos militaires que là
où il n'ya pas de transfert de
compétences il ne saurait y avoir de
primauté du droit européen et puis
restauré penser pour nous seul et non
pas avoir cette sous traitance délégué
aux américains de sécurité penser notre
sécurité la puissance pour nous les
européens avec les britanniques sans
doute avec ce pilier de l'otan et puis
aussi avec des grands programmes
d'armement je ne crois pas à une armée
aujourd'hui européenne par contre il y
attache main qu'il faut qu'on
entreprenne et enfin et pour conclure
chers collègues je pense que faire le
choix penser la puissance c'est écarter
de façon définitive
pour le moyen terme les perspectifs
fédéraliste elles ne peuvent
qu'affaiblir le seul instrument de
puissance que nous avons aujourd'hui en
europe qui sont les nations les nations
qui sont les dépositaires de la volonté
des peuples qu'est ce que nous montre
l'ukraine c'est que la guerre c'est un
choc des volontés et que depuis périclès
il n'y a pas de meilleure arme que la
volonté des peuples et que la volonté
des peuples au jour d'aujourd'hui au
moment où je vous parle réside dans les
nations qui peuvent coopérer mais c'est
si fondamental alors oui pour conclure
ce que je veux dire ici solennellement
ce soir dans cet hémicycle du sénat
c'est que le président de la république
a eu raison de qualifier cette guerre de
tournant historique
mais dans ce tournant historique il peut
y avoir un chemin français ce chemin
français ce sera le chemin de la liberté
le chemin de la souveraineté le chemin
de la nation parce que c'est l'histoire
de france parce que c'est la france dans
l'histoire et parce que c'est ce que
demandent à cor et à cri les arts à la
main aujourd'hui les ukrainiens le
peuple ukrainien un jour malraux que
vous connaissez que vous lisez monsieur
le premier ministre la loi avait dit la
france n'est la france que lorsque elles
portent une part de l'espérance du monde
eh bien oui aujourd'hui la france porte
aussi une part de l'espérance du monde
ou plutôt une part de l'espérance
ukrainienne aujourd'hui mes chers
collègues nous sommes tous ukrainiens
alors oui vive la république vive la
france et surtout vive l'ukraine libre
[Applaudissements]
policiers